Pretty insulting.
Now, that's the feeling inside
Vice President Harris's orbit.
But what Senator
Elizabeth Warren said or didn't
just a few weeks ago.
Now, that's
according to brand new
CNN reporting just out this morn
What happened
when Warren was asked by a Bosto
radio station
whether or not President
Biden should run again?
This is what she had to say.
Yes, he should run again.
And he is running again
because he has gotten a tremendo
done.
It's been two years
he's had this hideous possible m
in the United States Senate
and only
a very small majority in the Hou
And yet look at what we've done
But when when Warren was asked a
whether or not Harris
should be part of the ticket,
this is what she had to say.
I really want to defer
to what makes Biden
comfortable on his team.
I've known Kamala for a long tim
I like Kamala.
I knew her back when she was
when she was attorney general
and I was still teaching.
And we worked on the housing
crisis together.
So we go way back.
But they need they have to be a
And my sense is they are.
I don't mean that by suggesting
I think there are any problems.
Hmm.
So there are some news about wha
transpired next.
And for that, let's
bring in
CNN's Isaac Dovere to break down
all of his new reporting.
You see the headline there
on your screen.
Democratic leaders
want the party to stop its Kamal
Harris piling ahead of 2024.
So tell us about this phone call
that didn't quite happen.
Well, two phone calls.
Warren made that comment.
The end of January,
she immediately
realized that there had been a f
there and from her perspective o
And they put out a statement say
that's not what she meant to imp
that there was any problem
with the vice president.
Then she called the vice
president twice trying.
From our report,
he says
to apologize, to say
it's not unintentional here
Didn't mean to make a snub.
And Harris has so far not called
And as that that could happen an
It's six weeks.
And but among
almost everybody that we spoke w
who is anywhere near the vice pr
there is a fury over this.
And it's
because not just
what Elizabeth Warren said,
but because it feels to them
like another one of these
someone else
not showing respect
to the vice president,
not showing appreciation for the
that Kamala Harris has done.
They feel like they get it all t
They get it from all sides.
And they are extremely mad
about what happened to Elizabeth
And as the reporting that we did
shows us
also that there are a lot of Dem
who are starting to think like,
hey, maybe for
a lot of bigger reasons here,
we need to stop this.
Kamala Harris pile on.
Yeah, it's it's
such an interesting dynamic.
And yet this is Democrats
who are
concerned about Kamala Harris
and the pushback
from the vice president's office
And you mentioned the cleanup fr
from Elizabeth Warren camp.
After her statement
came out on that radio station,
she said their office
said, I fully support the presid
and vice president
election together
and never intended to imply othe
That same day,
this tweet came out from Preside
with Kamala Harris
proud of what we've gotten done
And I'm sure there was no coinci
in the timing there.
But look,
the Isaac's reporting gets to wh
a lot of Democrats
feel about the vice president
and her being on the ticket,
without a doubt.
But the reality is, if
if the president runs
for reelection, as expected,
she will be on the ticket
I mean, it would create much mor
for trying to remove her.
So, yes,
there are Democrats out there
who sort of wish she wasn't.
But the reality is,
if she was
over shining or outshining the p
that would be critical as well.
So I think the vice president,
she is very difficult.
There's no a rulebook for this.
The first female vice
president even harder.
But look,
she has some political challenge
She's created a lot of these
things on her own.
She's not necessarily found a la
but she does
have some supporters out there
who would like to see the White
her more
African-American voters,
the core of this Democratic Part
who are so critical, really like
So it's a fine line here for a
for them to watch.
But when the Republicans believe
that she will be
a central part of the 20,
24 campaign
because they are already
planning on saying
you're really running against
Kamala Harris
because Joe Biden may not
finish his term.
So she will be a central part
of the campaign regardless.
And she has pushed back
and her campus push back about t
calling this nothing
but political chatter.
I think that it is very importan
to focus on the needs
of the American people and not
political chatter
out of Washington, D.C..
Joe Biden intends
has said he intends to run
for reelection as president.
And I intend to run with him
as vice president of the United
Know.
But her approval rating has drop
just like President Biden has dr
It was 50% in June.
2021 down to 39% now, according
Fox News poll recently.
So this is an issue, too,
that she has to contend, certain
And I think a lot of the her low
approval ratings
is not just because she's obviou
part of the Biden administration
but she has been dealt
a lot of projects,
a lot of priorities
that are really difficult topics
a lot of the things that you def
to a vice president.
Obviously, the issue
with the migration crisis
and the root causes from Central
And I do think some of her suppo
want the White House
to kind of put her in a position
where she can
succeed, can thrive a little bit
I think she's actually found
a little bit of a lane
with leading the administration'
response on abortion, particular
after the decision.
If that's an issue where Preside
has not necessarily
been the most comfortable
and most potent messenger.
And I think
people at Harris and Circle
have been really happy with
how she's been kind of the point
for the White House on that issu
And in your reporting,
I think this is what senior aide
President Harris said, who
they knew what Mike Pence was do
Is it
does she at getting more critici
than other VP's in the past?
I mean,
I think it is
that that question that comes up
not just about Mike Pence,
but obviously the immediate pred
there, as Jeff was saying,
this is a really hard job
to be vice president
when it comes to Kamala Harris,
who has all of this
extra attention to her
because of who she is,
because of who she is demographi
because of the first all of that
There is this question of
how do you make her a star
when actually the star of the sh
for the Biden White House
is, of course, Joe Biden.
And they don't want to
have her outshine the president,
but they want her to figure out
to shine
a little bit more than she has s
We'll see how they decide to pla
in the 20, 24 campaign
assuming there is one.
All indications are that Biden w
We'll see.